let's head straight to the phones and
talk to Eric and Illinois hi Eric how
are you I'm good Dave thanks for taking
my call
sure man what's up I am currently about
90 grand and unsecured credit card debt
I'm fourteen months done with a debt
settlement program through a company and
I'm starting to second-guess whether or
not I should have done this and what are
my options should I withdraw from the
program should I continue doing what I'm
doing can I file bankruptcy it's 90
thousand dollars in credit cards yes
you've been with them nine months so
you're nine months or east yeah I'm
sorry fourteen months 14 months I'm
sorry so you're at least 14 months
behind right yes because you stopped
paying them and so did they correct and
then the they've been taking a payment
from you every month and they're
building it up to make lump sum offers
and try to settle after they put you in
to default on every one of these right
correct yeah people suck they're
complete scam artists and then worse
than that that's the theory of how it's
supposed to work but worse than that
they haven't actually followed through
and gotten the settlements done and they
don't return your calls or emails is
that right okay yeah you got to stay on
them yeah they're in common I would have
an answer for you when you when you call
them back yeah they're incompetent and
they don't care and they've not executed
on what they promised and what they
promised to start with was a bad plan
but they haven't even executed on that
and that's what we run into man I'm so
sorry I can hear your voice man you were
trying to get help
[Music]
what is your household income on the
books I'd make probably about 70 what's
that mean
what is off the books mean well I also
well I also deliver pizzas and I
probably make about two grand a month
take home
with that okay so we're dealing with a
hundred thousand are you single yes okay
and other debt that you have other than
this ninety thousand nothing I don't
over the bed they're not but I just paid
off my snap-on tool account which was
sixteen hundred bucks and my car which
is sixteen hundred bucks so I don't have
any other debt out there what do you do
for a living I'm a diesel mechanic Oh
thus the snap-on tools okay good so
you're paying cash for that stuff from
now on as you do need tools to do your
business oh good news is decent mechanic
can make some money why aren't you doing
more diesel mechanicing than delivering
pizzas you make more money on your sod
house it's yeah I don't really have a
good answer for that except that I
haven't found anything that's uh I can
do part-time before you know okay or
show you three hangers for side jobs
yeah shade tree or whatever okay yeah
I'd be poking around looking for that
because you as you know you're a pretty
valuable commodity I mean I know these
little mechanics that when they're
cranking it up they're doing work in a
bunch of hours but they're making 100k
and so you're making it your main 100k
that you're doing it through pizzas and
doing it the hard way so alright so
here's the deal okay if you file
bankruptcy what will occur is of course
your credit is destroyed oh hello
your credits already destroyed right
it's your default and your own ninety
thousand dollars worth of credit cards
for fourteen months your credit screwed
agreed agreed
okay bankruptcy well I mean it maybe
it's an 8 out of 10 and bankruptcy is a
10 out of 10 so you'll just finish it
off but it's already on its last legs so
we're not worried about your credit
that's not our goal number one goal
number one is for Eric to get his life
back
hmm from all of these shysters that
you've gotten involved with from credit
card companies to debt relief companies
so if you file bankruptcy it makes it go
away
and the credit is destroyed so chapter 7
bankruptcy is a possibility I've you
Bank
see from a moral perspective to be like
divorce sometimes it happens to good
people but I would if I were there and I
went through a bankruptcy in my 20s and
so I've experienced the hell that it is
it's not a fun process
it's an anal exam you won't like it
um the you know it's just it's it's it's
bad
and so but aside from that I would want
to know from a character standpoint that
I had done everything I could have saved
my marriage and then some more before I
actually went through a divorce I'd want
to know and I did I left it all on the
field
I had no regrets I had done everything I
knew how to do before I filed and so
that's how I'm gonna answer the question
if I were you I would file bankruptcy
only after I've done everything I could
do now I can give you some stuff to try
if you want to do that yes I'm willing
to go it's been all called debt relief
people up and tell them they get no more
money and you're not working with him
anymore cancel it okay so how much
you've been sending them a month 11:45
and how much can you scrape together if
you go hog wild and crazy'
can you save $3,000 a month definitely I
just started doing your budget at in the
last couple weeks I just started
listening to you in the last couple
weeks I know what we're gonna do is make
a list of these great about there make a
list of these credit cards smallest to
largest you're not gonna pay them
anymore
you've already quit paying them they're
already in default we're gonna leave
them there that'll keep them somewhat
pliable I think that over the next 12
months you can settle this for somewhere
around 25 cents on the dollar so
somewhere around twenty thousand dollars
makes you free but it's going to entail
a lot of hours of you on the phone with
absolute morons called credit card
collectors and negotiating with them
okay so you call up what's your smallest
credit card ah probably six grand I
don't have it yet
let's make that we use that as our
example that's your smallest one you
call them up and you say I have $2,000
do you want it I have $90,000 in other
credit card companies if you don't want
it I'm gonna call the next guy on the
list do you want it or not as settlement
in full for this debt and you begin to
argue with them and you get them to
$2,000 30 cents on the dollar 20 cents
on the dollar in lump sum cash you can
only do that as you pile up the cash
each month at three or four thousand a
month right right making sense to you
yeah so you settle the smallest one then
you sell the next smallest one then you
sell on the next smallest one I really
think you can settle this for around
twenty twenty-five thousand dollars and
I think you're debt-free in a year and
your credit don't begin to heal after
that and you're not bankrupt you just
need a plan now you've got a lot of
heartache dealing with credit card
collectors for the next year they're a
pain in the butt you're not dealing with
intelligent life it's the island of
misfit toys it's a problem get it in
writing every time you do this and do
not give them electronic access to your
checking account I'm gonna walk with you
Eric we're gonna give you a ram z+
financial peace and a financial
counsellor to help you for free for the
next year we're gonna get you out of
this if you'll walk it I'll show you how
hold on